[Music]
welcome back to all the record where we
talking about
what we got ryan maybe
hey we're just talking about stupid
things we did in junior high like
stealing car signs and glue into our
backpacks those are pretty cool
after getting like an accuracy to sign
your jan sport with a white owl pen
[ __ ] that used to be cool and now sucks
but then if you think about it you go
that was actually pretty [ __ ] cool
now i think you look at it now like man
that's [ __ ]
weird loser behavior what do you think
kids do now like what's the equivalent
[ __ ] you're right is that but
internet based yeah yeah like pranking
in
a grocery shop like they're screen
capping acura signs and then
photoshopping it on backpacks or 3d
printing it
3d printing yeah cyber bullying people
like what do kids do nowadays for fun
nobody even
sounds like a soul well i don't know
i feel like they do the same [ __ ] we did
like video games [ __ ]
chill but then now instead is it mostly
video games now i think they're
indoors way more though yeah yeah well
because of kovit too
but even before they could probably like
do what you call it like those um
like like streaming live watch parties
all that [ __ ] like things that we do
now but like they kind of chat roulette
a lot that don't have [ __ ]
technology they're probably still doing
the same [ __ ] we did for sure like a kid
without ipad probably stole a shitload
of cars
when we were like 12 13 and didn't have
all those toys
like you know i mean whereas like kids
are at 12 and 13 now it's like
this is this can take up four hours you
got a phone and a tablet probably
you know what you don't see you don't
see like toilet paper in the tree
anymore
yeah tiping is don't have to see what
happens really
i have a cousin who just got tp the
other day and i was like okay they're
still doing that [ __ ]
because he called me for help he's like
what should i do just take it what are
you talking about
just take it just roll it back up yeah
well he was like he was like
i want to get revenge on these guys i'm
like yeah no that's good like he's a
full-grown adult
yeah but don't like take weapons to
school or nothing well the revenge is
the eggs if you get teepee you egg
somebody
or you put shirts harder oh he's a kid
sugarcane
you guys did that [ __ ] the vietnamese
people would throw nook mom uh fish
oh i never did that you ever fork
somebody's lawn what's that i did that
you go to costco you get 500 forks like
for like 20 bucks and then you put them
all on their lawn like
so they're face ups yeah and they come
out and it's like [ __ ]
forks everywhere i think the kids today
will only use biodegradable forks
that's true they're not gonna use that
that's that they're like that's plastic
waste dude
the best [ __ ] is um i had a buddy who
was kind of an
uh no i look back um we did this thing
called the festival of forks
where um we hit like seven houses in one
night and when i looked back i realized
that they were all the chicks who turned
them down
uh oh
but looking back i'm like oh wait those
were all chicks who you liked and they
didn't like him
that's some in-cell [ __ ] yeah and you
were like
the accomplice i was just laughing my
ass off to the whole level that's
pretty rough though right you know why
because that guy knew steve was down to
fork some houses i was hella down dude
hey but since you've moved do you see
more kids playing outside now
yeah way more at the park you see a lot
of kids playing because that's
one thing i noticed that's totally
different from our
like generation in l.a yeah i don't see
kids like playing around
[ __ ] and just by themselves because i
remember seeing
mobs of [ __ ] kids on bicycles you
know i see nowadays is kids just going
to
get acai bowls and [ __ ] and like green
smoothies that's all i see nowadays
are you talking about like 10 year olds
in like san marino just
everywhere hollywood i remember like
there'll be like 10 kids
on [ __ ] bmx bikes just going all over
the place yeah i see that so
like stranger things like the park that
we go to um
there's all kinds of age groups so you
have like kids like tycho or maybe two
or three years older
they use the playground the right way
because they just figured out how to
climb they go down the slide
then you know when you're like in junior
high you're like too cool for school
so you're climbing on top of the jungle
gym right on top of the slide
so then you have i see like taika
looking at him like oh man that guy's a
[ __ ] god
that's some cool [ __ ] he's got a big old
dude bart's like i'm a [ __ ] god
so yeah you do see all these age groups
like mixing and stuff at least that
hasn't changed
yeah yeah hey if you're a kid leave a
comment below let us know what you guys
up to
what do you do for fun it sounds like do
kids do nowadays
is i i question i think about this all
the time like how does it because it you
know it's a generational thing it always
changes right with the suburb life you
don't see that much in l.a
yeah that's true do you feel like
with less uh i guess like resources when
we're younger right whether it be like
television channels to like uh
technology in general social media i
think
everything's accessible on the internet
now right before i feel like we had to
rely so much on imagination
do you feel like kids nowadays maybe
lacking imagine you've seen some kids
minecraft
lands and [ __ ] oh yeah sure they're
making like cities it's a different
ecosystem that their imagination
hell yeah instead of popsicle sticks now
it's [ __ ] minecraft
or they have more inspiration for even
more imagination instead of
mud from their backyard now they could
build a whole entire castle
instead of legos they're they're
building like [ __ ] castles and [ __ ]
minecraft that's crazy it must be pretty
[ __ ] hard to like lie
nowadays as a kid you know when kids
[ __ ] lie and they make up [ __ ] yeah
kids nowadays you can just look it up
and confirm you're fact-checked yeah you
can fact check everything but as a kid
you could totally make someone feel like
an idiot i make up all these people are
fact-checking
people don't people don't really
fact-check adults don't really backtrack
because you
so you're fact checking you're seeing
something different from someone else's
factor the worst thing is we have
internet now
in this building we still don't check
this [ __ ] why would we yeah he could
have been lying about all that [ __ ]
earlier
uh people get more what do you call it
like
afraid of of like physical danger for
kids like like the bubble boy
concept right cause like i think we were
we just got scraped the [ __ ] up and we
were able to play outside
and then like the newer generation it's
more like no that's too risky that's too
dangerous
because the difference i've seen too is
uh the usage of helmets
oh yeah i see so many kids with helmets
there are a lot of kids
with helmets i never seen that growing
up and i and people used to make fun of
kids with helmets on
yeah oh hell yeah you should put on your
handlebar you're like [ __ ]
they got elbow pads now they look like
[ __ ] medieval knights now dude
they're going larping i mean it's a good
thing just doesn't understand the
comments i protect your brain and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah it's good helmet yeah
yeah that's important but you look like
when i learned snowboarding and all this
stuff i don't wear i didn't wear helmets
and then like when you go to the slopes
now everyone's [ __ ] wearing a helmet
yeah dude sonny bono didn't wear a
helmet he probably should have
you heard about that oh one guy into the
tree right into the tree well tycho when
he was
first riding a bike we bought him a
bumblebee helmet because he was cute
but then now when he's riding his bike
he wants to go get his helmet now i
don't wear that [ __ ]
loser yeah he looks like a little loser
yeah bumblebee who the [ __ ] you botching
that's
not not to wear a helmet like don't
protect your head protect your swag
there's gonna be chicks at the park you
[ __ ] idiot take that [ __ ] off i'm
trying to get beat up come on man
yeah this would be chicks with the [ __ ]
yeah dying from no swag hurts more too
yeah yeah it lasts longer it mattered a
lot it's a more painful death
could you guys ride bikes with no hands
yeah i still don't know how to do it i
don't know how the [ __ ] people did that
why did that [ __ ] wow i ride the bike
and i'd let go and then i'm just oh
[ __ ] dude i couldn't even ride a bike so
i was like 11. remember those bicycles
that look like
that look like motorcycles the bicycle
oh that was so cool
yeah it was dressed up like a dirt bike
or something but it was just a [ __ ]
bicycle
i thought those kids were the coolest
privileged yeah i had a buddy who could
not just ride no hands like i could but
he could stand the [ __ ] up
with no hands like that that's justin
that's just circus [ __ ] no he stands on
the handlebars
oh really yeah he has one foot on the
chair
or the seat and one foot on the
handlebar and he deserves the bicycle
that's insane his dad was also like a
former like bmx racer oh
that guy does everything just just in
yeah he does literally
yeah he's genetic not real skilled yeah
you're born with it yeah yeah it's not
as fun dude
i can't get props right i was uh i was
really [ __ ] up because my cousin
learned how to ride without his hands on
a bike uh before me
and he's like barely younger than me but
you know when you're just like older
you're just like kind of a dick
so one time he was like riding the
cul-de-sac with no hands and i
i took a [ __ ] blow ball i threw it at
his bike with
my hands and he fell over and scraped
the [ __ ] off i should have had hands
should i handle dude that must have been
funny as [ __ ] i did that to joe like
last year
[Laughter]
he was on a skateboard i [ __ ] threw
my shoe at it
never told me it's like when you when
you try and describe it like it's like
when everybody gets in trouble in your
child like what happened
and then you described me like oh that's
very stupid
yeah but in the moment you're like yeah
i'ma [ __ ] do this right now
okay the funny thing is trying to
describe it where you don't incriminate
yourself yeah
well you're like trying to think of a
way that what happened it's just like
we were just playing with the ball and
then i just threw it and i hit him
yeah i just threw it i don't know like i
don't know what's happening it always
gets out of hand though it's pretty
funny
that's what happened to me when i
[ __ ] threw a ball at the chandelier
and shattered it
like one i shattered one of the things
it was like my aunt's house so like all
the asian families are there they came
into the room
they go what happened i go i just was
bouncing the ball in my leg like i
always do and then it just went up oh my
oh then my whole family came in and went
recreate it
break the other bulb and i sat there and
i was just like that's so hard
come on come on come on i just couldn't
[ __ ] do it
dude that's so funny i'd be like what
happened is you got a shitty [ __ ] to
learn
[ __ ] filipino family forensics man
dude my friend
yeah we were chasing each other around
and he thought it would be a great idea
to pick up dog [ __ ] with his bare hands
and chase me with it
and then he caught me and [ __ ] hit me
on the back
and smeared it oh
god i used to take basketballs on the
playground and mushroom and dog [ __ ]
and just leave them [ __ ] love that
you were an [ __ ] dude i love that
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
did that
every [ __ ] day i couldn't you were
every day i saw a ball and [ __ ] i
never left them alone what i always
combine the elements you're that guy
that's the worst [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
satisfying to see the [ __ ] guys
recess gets out every run someone grabs
it they're passing it
[ __ ] all over that roll dude you're the
guy who takes the basketball net off so
we can't even have a basketball
and every time you see you can take it
off again and throw it in the trash or
something [ __ ]
i didn't know that was the thing that is
a [ __ ] thing in bellflower it's a
[ __ ] thing thanks to me
god that's disgusting huh
you used to try and get the tetherballs
locked up you know when you like
swinging
tetherball in such a way that it like
locks over itself
you should try and do that i did that
yeah
over the [ __ ] telephone wires that
that was a kid thing
yeah yeah how much people do that
nowadays i still see that i said
yeah certain neighborhoods you see that
that's hilarious
dude damn being a kid seems way more fun
than me yeah the repercussions are
hilarious walking around did you guys
ever have the water balloons that looked
like grenades
yeah yeah i told you i was not about
that sickest [ __ ] i ever saw yeah
when you played army did you use them oh
[ __ ] yeah that is something did they
ever blow up on you
[ __ ] yeah yeah of course dude i can't
believe you mentioned that
weren't they so cool yes that and the
the water balloon uh [ __ ]
parachute catapult sling oh bro oh dope
yeah
i wonder if kids still do that how could
that not still be fun i don't know
because cream trucks that drive around
he could probably buy all that stuff
like water guns and people don't shoot
each other you think karen's are
stopping a lot i think they're shooting
each other online
oh i mean look just look at water gun
the average water gun looks so comical
now but back then they look like [ __ ]
uzis
yeah yeah my favorite one was i had a i
had a uh
like a gatling gun kind of thing and it
would shoot
it was battery part power water uh a gun
and you can hit the button
and it'll be like yeah it was so sick
at the [ __ ] park with that chip dude
i still like the really really colorful
powerful
tubes that you would super screw on and
or the backpack oh
the backpack was the same backpack but
who had the [ __ ] voice command
yeah fire fire fire oh i never had that
i can't
that can't cause me to say i heard it
yeah
that kid walks outside everyone's coming
down on his ass
fire fire fire i heard it people said it
didn't work and i was like that's
[ __ ] sad no way
no way it worked were you guys nerf or a
super soaker
i like both yeah but nerf had some
creative ass [ __ ]
those things nerf crosstalk i always
lost my bullets one big ass dart
those will tell my god yeah yeah you
remember that [ __ ] the the uh
nerf bow and arrow it had one giant
missile no i totally remember but i
would get like the chinatown version
that wasn't like nerf branded
where you had to like do it yourself
with like an air pump yeah
you guys ever had like that china brand
[ __ ] straight up
war battles like in in a park where you
would get like the whole
you would just spread the word the whole
school and then you go to the park
and you'll see like 40 kids just coming
together you can fight
yeah and it looks like it's like a
straight up battle and you're just there
the the poor kids have the 25 cent
[ __ ] plastic ones
with the water that are leaking already
yeah
the rich kids had the [ __ ] backpack
super soakers
with unlimited water and [ __ ] you know
when you go to like the giant
[ __ ] bathtub like the community sinks
you know what i mean that everybody uses
outside of the park
and you're there and you're like opening
up your little thing you're trying to
like get as much water in there as
possible
it comes by with like two [ __ ]
backpacks and you're like
when you're throwing up that [ __ ]
adrenaline popping in there oh
with that little tab with the [ __ ]
plastic connected you gotta watch the
bubbles go up the smart [ __ ] was putting
ice cubes in the water so the
kids were like oh [ __ ] it's evil
that was the best you see this ah yeah
damn dude i want i'm pretty sure they
still do that [ __ ] we just haven't been
around kids in ages that might be
it that might be the reason why we're
losing it uh but yeah
you guys ever do capture the flag yeah
that was the best
capture flag was [ __ ] dope that was
my favorite thing in boy scouts because
we would do it when we went camping so
the terrain was always like
crazy and different and then the way we
played we always played at night
so um you would put the glow stick on
each end
so that way if someone start grabbed it
and was jetting back towards the
territory then you can see like a
glowing thing
that's so funny the cover of the night
it's like you can't see like when we
play like let's say on the rocks
on the beach like people are crawling
through the rocks and stuff it's cool
that's
crazy you guys ever used to play that
game called kill the carrier or like be
one person
and they would grab like whatever the
football is and everybody would try to
get them to the end zone
you guys ever do that and they would
just literally tackle you and like beat
you to [ __ ] before you get to the end is
this an excuse to jump one guy
you're one guy let's play kill the
character hey nick you're like
why i don't want playing but soon as you
when you would get to the end it was
very like
you've been watching by that point
watching
[ __ ] i've not heard that in so long yeah
what's that
it's an asian gang it's a chinese game
[ __ ] kids
very popular updates watching
dude that was pretty i don't know man i
i want to just go out and play
stupid-ass games like that but i think
everything is next level now
because like why would you have a super
soaker fight when you can do an airsoft
game
or paintball or paintball because when i
go to the airsoft
game i mean there's like 10 year olds
just
right there with full grown adults but
super soaker you could do it in the
front yard it's more accessible
it's fun yeah that's true i would [ __ ]
all of you up in laser tag not even
kidding let's play
laser tag no cap zero cap laser tag is
actually really fun for like a short
period of time that video of you
shooting tyka in the face
right is so funny a short period of time
yeah like 10 15 one round time one round
but once you're like
super sweaty or like once you recognize
your team [ __ ] sucks for some reason
you're like
yeah that's the thing it's like you
never know who you get paired up with
that laser tag so it could just ruin the
whole thing
you just go like this like the sensor
you can block the sensor with your hand
right yeah yeah but then the guy is
going to go on the speaker and go
can't do that but that guy's a loser
yeah so i don't care i'm a little shut
up intel
now now they have like vr have you guys
on the vr one
yeah those are [ __ ] cool oh we did we
played out uh
we we played that that was tough just
like a giant open room but then you put
on like the entire thing that was cool
but you're all on a team
no for us we were in turns yeah and then
you put in the
vr and then we worked the [ __ ]
turrets like oh yeah
yeah i can see and i can see those guys
in the game which is sick
yeah that is the ones like player versus
player ones with the
with the holy [ __ ] i never did that in
like big old rooms the best [ __ ] about
laser tag though is you i i like to camp
so i'm [ __ ] camping the whole time
that is pretty [ __ ] entertaining spot
yeah camping the battle zones bro
whatever the point zones are i'm [ __ ]
camping that [ __ ] the whole time
that's pretty [ __ ] funny i don't
leave where do you play laser tag
that the what is it yeah there's one
there's one like way the [ __ ] away
this for sure one in fullerton by the by
the uh fullerton
um bowling alley there's one in on
hamilton before really
i've never been there but there's one in
hamburg i also have been there
yeah yeah hey is that is that dying out
is all that stuff done
oh [ __ ] i'm camping your spawn point
the whole time i'm [ __ ] sitting on
that swing i think they're all right
here but when you go to like china you
go to like laser tag that's just
ridiculous
really yeah it's like actually it's got
like the non-usda lasers or some [ __ ]
not fda lasers like it's like i guess
just cheaper for them to have like giant
real estate areas
so they have like huge war zones with
like a bunch of different contraptions
and stuff
that's dope damn dude i would camp all
over that [ __ ] place
[Laughter]
no question you know what i enjoy as a
recent development as a game for
more uh adults though uh escape rooms
escape rooms or
because they weren't around when we were
younger and we either were too dumb to
figure out how to escape most of them
they're fun i get lost in the [ __ ]
ball piano hit or miss though actually
hit her
i think they need laser tag in them it
just keeps shooting you
with mental puzzles i like escape rooms
with like physical obstacles and you
have to like
oh there was a good one right you're not
scary for them when they have the
zombie maze but it's actual laser tag at
the same time as the maze no way that's
that's cool they have people dressed as
zombies with uh things on their neck you
guys blast them
yeah and they'll actually like come at
you and you got to go through the whole
thing and then score at the end
see that's a good idea that's that's
your [ __ ] right there great idea i love
that
can you camp in it
you